- When cooking
(fun jazzy music)
in the kitchen, it's very important
to use the best tools for the job.
This will ensure maximum flavor
as well as optimal textures.
Hi, my name's Alexis, and today
we're going to talk about the difference
between three common household pans.
Let's start with the nonstick pan.
This is probably the most
common pan for beginner cooks.
These are fairly inexpensive, and due
to their nonstick surface,
they're super easy to clean.
To increase the longevity of
your pan, you need to ensure
that you're taking proper
care of the nonstick surface.
For example, when you're
making scrambled eggs,
you should always be using
silicone or wooden tools.
And that goes for all
other dishes as well.
To get the best results
from your nonstick pan,
we recommend you cook delicate dishes
like eggs, pancakes, grilled cheese,
and lighter fish such as tilapia.
Proteins like steak, chicken thighs,
burgers, or salmon aren't
ideal for a nonstick pan,
as those require high heat.
If you're looking for easy cleanup
and don't wanna make dishes that require
high heat, this is the pan for you.
So now let's talk about cast-irons.
I think everybody should
own one of these pans.
Cast-iron pans are
exceptionally versatile.
These sturdy pans can be used
on the stovetop as well as in the oven.
Cast-iron pans are not only affordable,
but if you take proper care of them,
they can last for decades.
These long-lasting pans can be used
to cook an array of dishes, from steak,
fruit cobbler, and even frittata.
You can cook nearly everything
with a cast-iron pan,
but for beginner cooks,
they may seem intimidating.
Pans need to be treated
before their first use,
and the cleanup is more involved
than with a nonstick pan.
If you're willing to do the cleanup,
cast-iron pans are a worthwhile
addition to any kitchen.
Now let's talk about
our third and final pan.
Stainless steel is without a doubt
my favorite pan to use in the kitchen.
These pans are built
tough, and like cast-iron,
can be used on the
stovetop or in the oven.
They're particularly good
when you want a nice sear on a protein.
You can truly cook everything
with a stainless steel pan:
salmon, sauteed vegetables,
risotto, and even eggs.
The fear around using
the stainless steel pan
is the idea that food will stick.
To prevent this, you need
to make sure you're using
a pre-heated pan and the
appropriate amount of oil.
So, here I have two chicken
thighs, and I'm gonna show you
just how easy it is
(clattering)
to make sure your food doesn't stick.
First things first,
let's pre-heat the pan.
I'm going to add about
two teaspoons of oil,
just enough to coat the bottom of the pan.
Once the oil begins to shimmer,
I'm going to add the seasoned
chicken, skin side down.
(sizzling)
I'm going to let the chicken rest
in the pan for a few minutes.
Once the chicken begins to pull away
from the pan, it should be ready to flip.
See?!
It's so easy.
Check out that beautiful golden skin.
I'm going to let them brown
for a few more minutes
on the other side, and then I'm going
to finish them off in the oven.
After you remove the
chicken from the oven,
there's going to be some brown bits
at the bottom of the pan.
This is called the foundation.
At this point, you can go
ahead and scrub the pan,
or what I prefer to do is take advantage
of the amazing flavor from the chicken fat
and make a really simple pan sauce.
Reduce the stock for a few minutes,
then add garlic, thyme, and
a bit of butter, and stir.
Pour the sauce over the
chicken and you've got
a great, easy dinner and a clean pan.
So, as you can see, stainless steel
can do everything that a
nonstick and a cast-iron can do.
In my opinion, it's the most
versatile pan out there.